So, there is a lot of
Today we're going to not talk
about sorting.
This is an exciting new
development.
We know that what we're looking
We're going to talk about
another problem,
a related problem,
but a different problem.
We're going to talk about
another problem that we would
like to solve in linear time.
Last class we talked about we
could do sorting in linear time.
To do that we needed some
additional assumptions.
Today we're going to look at a
problem that really only needs
linear time, even though at
first glance it might look like
it requires sorting.
So this is going to be an
easier problem.
The problem is I give you a
bunch of numbers.
Let's call them elements.
And they are in some array,
let's say.
And they're in no particular
order, so unsorted.
I want to find the kth smallest
element.
This is called the element of
rank k.
In other words,
I have this list of numbers
which is unsorted.
And, if I were to sort it,
I would like to know what the
kth element is.
But I'm not allowed to sort it.
One solution to this problem,
this is the naÔve algorithm,
is you just sort and then
return the kth element.
This is another possible
definition of the problem.
And we would like to do better
than that.
So you could sort,
what's called the array A,
and then return A[k].
That is one thing we could do.
And if we use heap sort or
mergesort, this will take n lg n
time.
We would like to do better than
n lg n.
Ideally linear time.
The problem is pretty natural,
straightforward.
It has various applications.
Depending on how you choose k,
k could be any number between 1
and n.
For example,
if we choose k=1 that element
has a name.
Any suggestions of what the
name is?
The minimum.
That's easy.
Any suggestions on how we could
find the minimum element in an
array in linear time?
Right.
Just scan through the array.
Keep track of what the smallest
number is that you've seen.
The same thing with the
maximum, k=n.
These are rather trivial.
But a more interesting version
of the order statistic problem
is to find the median.
This is either k equals n plus
1 over 2 floor or ceiling.
I will call both of those
elements medians.
Finding the median of an
unsorted array in linear time is
quite tricky.
And that sort of is the main
goal of this lecture,
is to be able to find the
medians.
For free we're going to be able
to find the arbitrary kth
smallest element,
but typically we're most
interested in finding the
median.
And on Friday in recitation
you'll see why that is so
useful.
There are all sorts of
situations where you can use
median for really effective
divide-and-conquer without
having to sort.
You can solve a lot of problems
in linear time as a result.
And we're going to cover today
two algorithms for finding order
statistics.
Both of them are linear time.
The first one is randomized,
so it's only linear expected
time.
And the second one is
worst-case linear time,
and it will build on the
randomized version.
Let's start with a randomize
divide-and-conquer algorithm.
This algorithm is called
rand-select.
And the parameters are a little
bit more than what we're used
to.
The order statistics problem
you're given an array A.
And here I've changed notation
and I'm looking for the ith
smallest element,
so i is the index I'm looking
for.
And I'm also going to change
the problem a little bit.
And instead of trying to find
it in the whole array,
I'm going to look in a
particular interval of the
array, A from p up to q.
We're going to need that for a
recursion.
This better be a recursive
algorithm because we're using
divide-and-conquer.
Here is the algorithm.
With a base case.
It's pretty simple.
Then we're going to use part of
the quicksort algorithm,
randomized quicksort.
We didn't actually define this
subroutine two lectures ago,
but you should know what it
does, especially if you've read
the textbook.
This says in the array A[p...q]
pick a random element,
so pick a random index between
p and q, swap it with the first
element, then call partition.
And partition uses that first
element to split the rest of the
array into less than or equal to
that random partition and
greater than or equal to that
partition.
This is just picking a random
partition element between p and
q, cutting the array in half,
although the two sizes may not
be equal.
And it returns the index of
that partition element,
some number between p and q.
And we're going to define k to
be this particular value,
r minus p plus 1.
And the reason for that is that
k is then the rank of the
partition element.
This is in A[p...q].
Let me draw a picture here.
We have our array A.
It starts at p and ends at q.
There is other stuff,
but for this recursive all we
care about is p up to q.
We pick a random partition
element, say this one,
and we partition things so that
everything in here,
let's call this r,
is less than or equal to A[r]
and everything up here is
greater than or equal to A[r].
And A[r] is our partition
element.
After this call,
that's what the array looks
like.
And we get r.
We get the index of where
partition element is stored.
The number of elements that are
less than or equal to A[r] and
including r is r minus p plus 1.
There will be r minus p
elements here,
and we're adding 1 to get this
element.
And, if you start counting at
1, if this is rank 1,
rank 2, this element will have
rank k.
That's just from the
construction in the partition.
And now we get to recurse.
And there are three cases --
-- depending on how i relates
to k.
Remember i is the rank that
we're looking for,
k is the rank that we happen to
get out of this random
partition.
We don't have much control over
k, but if we're lucky i=k.
That's the element we want.
Then we just return the
partition element.
More likely is that the element
we're looking for is either to
the left or to the right.
And if it's to the left we're
going to recurse in the
left-hand portion of the array.
And if it's to the right we're
going to recurse in the
right-hand portion.
So, pretty straightforward at
this point.
I just have to get all the
indices right.
Either we're going to recurse
on the part between p and r
minus 1, that's this case.
The rank we're looking for is
to the left of the rank of
element A[r].
Or, we're going to recurse on
the right part between r plus 1
and q.
Where we recurse on the left
part the rank we're looking for
remains the same,
but when we recurse on the
right part the rank we're
looking for gets offset.
Because we sort of got rid of
the k elements over here.
I should have written this
length is k.
We've sort of swept away k
ranks of elements.
And now within this array we're
looking for the i minus kth
smallest element.
That's the recursion.
We only recurse once.
And random partition is not a
recursion.
That just takes linear time.
And the total amount of work
we're doing here should be
linear time plus one recursion.
And we'd next like to see what
the total running time is in
expectation, but let's first do
a little example --
-- to make this algorithm
perfectly clear.
Let's suppose we're looking for
the seventh smallest element in
this array.
And let's suppose,
just for example,
that the pivot we're using is
just the first element.
So, nothing fancy.
I would have to flip a few
coins in order to generate a
random one, so let's just pick
this one.
If I partition at the element
6, this is actually an example
we did two weeks ago,
and I won't go through it
again, but we get the same
array, as we did two weeks ago,
namely 2, 5,
3, 6, 8, 13,
10 and 11.
If you run through the
partitioning algorithm,
that happens to be the order
that it throws the elements
into.
And this is our position r.
This is p here.
It's just 1.
And q is just the end.
And I am looking for the
seventh smallest element.
And it happens when I run this
partition that 6 falls into the
fourth place.
And we know that means,
because all the elements here
are less than 6 and all the
elements here are greater than
6, if this array were sorted,
6 would be right here in
position four.
So, r here is 4.
Yeah?
The 12 turned into an 11?
This was an 11,
believe it or not.
Let me be simple.
Sorry.
Sometimes my ones look like
twos.
Not a good feature.
That's an easy way to cover.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't try that on exams.
Oh, that one was just a two.
No.
Even though we're not sorting
the array, we're only spending
00:13:37,000 --> 00:00:06,000
linear work here to partition by
We know that if we had sorted
the array 6 would fall here.
We don't know about these other
elements.
They're not in sorted order,
but from the properties of
partition we know 6 went the
right spot.
We now know rank of 6 is 4.
We happened to be looking for 7
and we happened to get this
number 4.
We want something over here.
It turns out we're looking for
10, I guess.
No, 11.
There should be eight elements
in this array,
so it's the next to max.
Max here is 13,
I'm cheating here.
The answer we're looking for is
00:14:14,000 --> 00:00:11,000
for is in the right-hand part
because the rank we're looking
00:14:20,000 --> 00:00:04,000
for is 7, which is bigger than
Now, what rank are we looking
for in here?
Well, we've gotten rid of four
elements over here.
It happened here that k is also
4 because p is 1 in this
example.
The rank of 6 was 4.
We throw away those four
elements.
Now we're looking for rank 7
minus 4 which is 3.
And, indeed,
the rank 3 element here is
still 11.
So, you recursively find that.
That's your answer.
Now that algorithm should be
pretty clear.
The tricky part is to analyze
it.
And the analysis here is quite
a bit like randomized quicksort,
although not quite as hairy,
so it will go faster.
But it will be also sort of a
nice review of the randomized
quicksort analysis which was a
bit tricky and always good to
see a couple of times.
We're going to follow the same
kind of outline as before to
look at the expected running
time of this algorithm.
And to start out we're going
to, as before,
look at some intuition just to
feel good about ourselves.
Also feel bad as you'll see.
Let's think about two sort of
extreme cases,
a good case and the worst case.
And I should mention that in
all of the analyses today we
assume the elements are
distinct.
It gets really messy if the
elements are not distinct.
And you may even have to change
the algorithms a little bit
because if all the elements are
equal, if you pick a random
element, the partition does not
do so well.
But let's assume they're all
distinct, which is the really
interesting case.
A pretty luck case --
I mean the best cases we
partition right in the middle.
The number of elements to the
left of our partition is equal
to the number of elements to the
right of our partition.
But almost as good would be
some kind of 1/10 to 9/10 split.
Any constant fraction,
we should feel that.
Any constant fraction is as
good as 1/2.
Then the recurrence we get is,
let's say at most,
this bad.
So, it depends.
If we have let's say 1/10 on
the left and 9/10 on the right
every time we do a partition.
It depends where our answer is.
It could be if i is really
small it's in the 1/10 part.
If i is really big it's going
to be in the 9/10 part,
or most of the time it's going
to be in the 9/10 part.
We're doing worst-case analysis
within the lucky case,
so we're happy to have upper
bounds.
I will say t(n) is at most t of
T(9/10n)+Theta(n).
Clearly it's worse if we're in
the bigger part.
What is the solution to this
recurrence?
Oh, solving recurrence was so
long ago.
What method should we use for
solving this recurrence?
The master method.
What case are we in?
Three.
Good.
You still remember.
This is Case 3.
We're looking at nlog_b(a).
b here is 10/9,
although it doesn't really
matter because a is 1.
log base anything of 1 is 0.
So, this is n^0 which is 1.
And n is polynomially larger
than 1.
This is going to be O(n),
which is good.
That is what we want,
linear time.
If we're in the lucky case,
great.
Unfortunately this is only
intuition.
And we're not always going to
get the lucky case.
We could do the same kind of
analysis as we did with
randomized quicksort.
If you alternate between lucky
and unlucky, things will still
be good, but let's just talk
about the unlucky case to show
how bad things can get.
And this really would be a
worst-case analysis.
The unlucky case we get a split
of 0:n-1.
Because we're removing the
partition element either way.
And there could be nothing less
than the partition element.
We have 0 on the left-hand side
and we have n-1 on the
right-hand side.
Now we get a recurrence like
T(n)=T(n-1) plus linear cost.
And what's the solution to that
recurrence?
n^2.
Yes.
This one you should just know.
It's n^2 because it's an
arithmetic series.
And that's pretty bad.
This is much,
much worse than sorting and
then picking the ith element.
In the worst-case this
algorithm really sucks,
but most of the time it's going
to do really well.
And, unless you're really,
really unlucky and every coin
you flip gives the wrong answer,
you won't get this case and you
will get something more like the
lucky case.
At least that's what we'd like
to prove.
And we will prove that the
expected running time here is
linear.
So, it's very rare to get
anything quadratic.
But later on we will see how to
make the worst-case linear as
well.
This would really,
really solve the problem.
Let's get into the analysis.
Now, you've seen an analysis
much like this before.
What do you suggest we do in
order to analyze this expected
time?
It's a divide-and-conquer
algorithm, so we kind of like to
write down the recurrence on
something resembling the running
time.
I don't need the answer,
but what's the first step that
we might do to analyze the
expected running time of this
algorithm?
Sorry?
Look at different cases,
yeah.
Exactly.
We have all these possible ways
that random partition could
split.
It could split 0 to the n-1.
It could split in half.
There are n choices where it
could split.
How can we break into those
cases?
Indicator random variables.
Cool.
Exactly.
That's what we want to do.
Indicator random variable
suggests that what we're dealing
with is not exactly just a
function T(n) but it's a random
variable.
This is one subtlety.
T(n) depends on the random
choices, so it's really a random
variable.
And then we're going to use
indicator random variables to
get a recurrence on T(n).
So, T(n) is the running time of
rand-select on an input of size
n.
And I am also going to write
down explicitly an assumption
about the random numbers.
That they should be chosen
independently from each other.
Every time I call random
partition, it's generating a
completely independent random
number from all the other times
I call random partition.
That is important,
of course, for this analysis to
work.
We will see why some point down
the line.
And now, to sort of write down
an equation for T(n) we're going
to define indicator random
variables, as you suggested.
And we will call it X_k.
And this is for all k=0...n-1.
Indicator random variables
either 1 or 0.
And it's going to be 1 if the
partition comes out k on the
left-hand side.
So say the partition generates
a k:n-k-1 split and it is 0
otherwise.
We have n of these indicator
random variables between
0...n-1.
And in each case,
no matter how the random choice
comes out, exactly one of them
will be 1.
All the others will be 0.
Now we can divide out the
running time of this algorithm
based on which case we're in.
That will sort of unify this
intuition that we did and get
all the cases.
And then we can look at the
expectation.
T(n), if we just split out by
cases, we have an upper bound
like this.
If we have 0 to n-1 split,
the worst is we have n-1.
Then we have to recurse in a
problem of size n-1.
In fact, it would be pretty
hard to recurse in a problem of
size 0.
If we have a 1 to n-2 split
then we take the max of the two
sides.
That's certainly going to give
us an upper bound and so on.
And at the bottom you get an
n-1 to 0 split.
This is now sort of
conditioning on various events,
but we have indicator random
variables to tell us when these
events happen.
We can just multiply each of
these values by the indicator
random variable and it will come
out 0 if that's not the case and
will come out 1 and give us this
value if that happens to be the
split.
So, if we add up all of those
we'll get the same thing.
This is equal to the sum over
all k of the indicator random
variable times the cost in that
case, which is t of max k,
and the other side,
which is n-k-1,
plus theta n.
This is our recurrence,
in some sense,
for the random variable
representing running time.
Now, the value will depend on
which case we come into.
We know the probability of each
of these events happening is the
same because we're choosing the
partition element uniformly at
random, but we cannot really
simplify much beyond this until
we take expectations.
We know this random variable
could be as big as n^2.
Hopefully it's usually linear.
We will take expectations of
both sides and get what we want.
Let's look at the expectation
of this random variable,
which is just the expectation,
I will copy over,
summation we have here so I can
work on this board.
I want to compute the
expectation of this summation.
What property of expectation
should I use?
Linearity, good.
We can bring the summation
outside.
Now I have a sum of
expectation.
Let's look at each expectation
individually.
It's a product of two random
variables, if you will.
This is an indicator random
variable and this is some more
complicated function,
some more complicated random
variable representing some
running time,
which depends on what random
choices are made in that
recursive call.
Now what should I do?
I have the expectation of the
product of two random variables.
Independence,
exactly.
If I know that these two random
variables are independent then I
know that the expectation of the
product is the product of the
expectations.
Now we have to check are they
independent?
I hope so because otherwise
there isn't much else I can do.
Why are they independent?
Sorry?
Because we stated that they
are, right.
Because of this assumption.
We assume that all the random
numbers are chosen
independently.
We need to sort of interpolate
that here.
These X_k's,
all the X_k's,
X_0 up to X_n-1,
so all the ones appearing in
this summation are dependent
upon a single random choice of
this particular call to random
partition.
All of these are correlated,
because if one of them is 1,
all the others are forced to be
00:30:44,000 --> 00:00:00,000
correlation among the X_k's.
But with respect to everything
that is in here,
and the only random part is
this T(max(kn-k-1)).
That is the reason that this
random variable is independent
from these.
The same thing as quicksort,
but I know some people got
confused about it a couple
lectures ago so I am
reiterating.
We get the product of
expectations,
E[X_k] E[T(max(kn-k-1))].
I mean the order n comes
outside, but let's leave it
inside for now.
There is no expectation to
compute there for order n.
Order n is order n.
What is the expectation of X_k?
1/n, because they're all chosen
with equal probability.
There is n of them,
so the expectation is 1/n.
The value is either 1 or 0.
We start to be able to split
this up.
We have 1/n times this expected
value of some recursive T call,
and then we have plus 1 over n
times order n,
also known as a constant,
but everything is summed up n
times so let's expand this.
I have the sum k=0 to n-1.
I guess the 1/n can come
outside.
And we have expectation of
[T(max(kn-k-1))].
Lots of nifty braces there.
And then plus we have,
on the other hand,
the sum k=0 to n-1.
Let me just write that out
again.
We have a 1/n in front and we
have a Theta(n) inside.
This summation is n^2.
And then we're dividing by n,
so this whole thing is,
again, order n.
Nothing fancy happened there.
This is really just saying the
expectation of order n is order
n.
Average value of order n is
order n.
What is interesting is this
part.
Now, what could we do with this
summation?
Here we start to differ from
randomized quicksort because we
have this max.
Randomized quicksort we had the
sum of T(k) plus T(n-k-1)
because we were making both
recursive calls.
Here we're only making the
biggest one.
That max is really a pain for
evaluating this recurrence.
How could I get rid of the max?
That's one way to think of it.
Yeah?
Exactly.
I could only sum up to halfway
and then double.
In other words,
terms are getting repeated
twice here.
When k=0 or when k=n-1,
I get the same T(n-1).
When k=1 or n-2,
I get the same thing,
2 and n-3.
What I will actually do is sum
from halfway up.
That's a little bit cleaner.
And let me get the indices
right.
Floor of n/2 up to n-1 will be
safe.
And then I just have E[T(k)],
except I forgot to multiply by
2, so I'm going to change this 1
to a 2.
And order n is preserved.
This is just because each term
is appearing twice.
I can factor it out.
And if n is odd,
I'm actually double-counting
somewhat, but it's certain at
most that.
So, that's a safe upper bound.
And upper bounds are all we
care about because we're hoping
to get linear.
And the running time of this
algorithm is definitely at least
linear, so we just need an upper
bounded linear.
So, this is a recurrence.
E[T(n)] is at most 2/n times
the sum of half the numbers
between 0 and n of
E[T(k)]+Theta(n).
It's a bit of hairy recurrence.
We want to solve it,
though.
And it's actually a little bit
easier than the randomized
quicksort recurrence.
We're going to solve it.
What method should we use?
Sorry?
Master method?
Master would be nice,
except that each of the
recursive calls is with a
different value of k.
The master method only works
when all the calls are with the
same value, same size.
Alas, it would be nice if we
could use the master method.
What else do we have?
Substitution.
When it's hard,
when in doubt,
use substitution.
I mean the good thing here is
we know what we want.
From the intuition at least,
which is now erased,
we really feel that this should
be linear time.
So, we know what we want to
prove.
And indeed we can prove it just
directly with substitution.
I want to claim there is some
constant c greater than zero
such that E[T(n)],
according to this recurrence,
is at most c times n.
Let's prove that over here.
As we guessed,
the proof is by substitution.
What that means is we're going
to assume, by induction,
that this inequality is true
for all smaller m.
I will just say 4 less than n.
And we need to prove it for n.
We get E[T(n)].
Now we are just going to expand
using the recurrence that we
have.
It's at most this.
I will copy that over.
And then each of these
recursive calls is with some
value k that is strictly smaller
than n.
Sorry, I copied it wrong,
floor of n over 2,
not zero.
And so I can apply the
induction hypothesis to each of
these.
This is at most c times k by
the induction hypothesis.
And so I get this inequality.
This c can come outside the
summation because it's just a
constant.
And I will be slightly tedious
in writing this down again,
because what I care about is
the summation here that is left
over.
This is a good old-fashioned
summation.
And if you remember back to
your summation tricks or
whatever, you should be able to
evaluate this.
If we started at zero and went
up to n minus 1,
that's just an arithmetic
series, but here we have the
tail end of an arithmetic
series.
And you should know,
at least up to theta,
what this is,
right?
n^2, yeah.
It's definitely T(n^2).
But we need here a slightly
better upper bond,
as we will see the constants
really matter.
What we're going to use is that
this summation is at most 3/8
times n^2.
And that will be critical,
the fact that 3/8 is smaller
than 1/2, I believe.
So it's going to get rid of
this 2.
I am not going to prove this.
This is an exercise.
When you know that it is true,
it's easy because you can just
prove it by induction.
Figuring out that number is a
little bit more work,
but not too much more.
So you should prove that by
induction.
Now let me simplify.
This is a bit messy,
but what I want is c times n.
Let's write it as our desired
value minus the residual.
And here we have some crazy
fractions.
This is 2 times 3 which is 6
over 8 which is 3/4,
right?
Here we have 1,
so we have to subtract up 1/4
to get 3/4.
And this should be,
I guess, 1/4 times c times n.
And then we have this theta n
with double negation becomes a
plus theta n.
That should be clear.
I am just rewriting that.
So we have what we want over
here.
And then we hope that this is
nonnegative because what we want
is that this less than or equal
to c times n.
That will be true,
provided this thing is
nonnegative.
And it looks pretty good
because we're free to choose c
however large we want.
Whatever constant is imbedded
in this beta notation is one
fixed constant,
whatever makes this recurrence
true.
We just set c to be bigger than
4 times that constant and then
this will be nonnegative.
So this is true for c
sufficiently large to dwarf that
theta constant.
It's also the base case.
I just have to make the cursory
mention that we choose c large
enough so that this claim is
true, even in the base case
where n is at most some
constant.
Here it's like 1 or so because
then we're not making a
recursive call.
What we get --
This algorithm,
randomize select,
has expected running time order
n, Theta(n).
The annoying this is that in
the worst-case,
if you're really,
really unlucky it's n^2.
Any questions before we move on
from this point?
This finished off the proof of
this fact that we have Theta(n)
expected time.
We already saw the n^2
worst-case.
All perfectly clear?
Good.
You should go over these
proofs.
They're intrinsically related
between randomized quicksort and
randomized select.
Know them in your heart.
This is a great algorithm that
works really well in practice
because most of the time you're
going to split,
say, in the middle,
somewhere between a 1/4 and 3/4
and everything is good.
It's extremely unlikely that
you get the n^2 worst-case.
It would have to happen with
like 1 over n^n probability or
something really,
really small.
But I am a theoretician at
least.
And it would be really nice if
you could get Theta(n) in the
worst-case.
That would be the cleanest
result that you could hope for
because that's optimal.
You cannot do better than
Theta(n).
You've got to look at the
elements.
So, you might ask,
can we get rid of this
worst-case behavior and somehow
avoid randomization and
guarantee Theta(n) worst-case
running time?
And you can but it's a rather
nontrivial algorithm.
And this is going to be one of
the most sophisticated that
we've seen so far.
It won't continue to be the
most sophisticated algorithm we
will see, but here it is.
Worst-case linear time order
statistics.
And this is an algorithm by
several, all very famous people,
Blum, Floyd,
Pratt, Rivest and Tarjan.
I think I've only met the B and
the R and the T.
Oh, no, I've met Pratt as well.
I'm getting close to all the
authors.
This is a somewhat old result,
but at the time it was a major
breakthrough and still is an
amazing algorithm.
Ron Rivest is a professor here.
You should know him from the R
in RSA.
When I took my PhD
comprehensives some time ago,
on the cover sheet was a joke
question.
It asked of the authors of the
worst-case linear time order
statistics algorithm,
which of them is the most rich?
Sadly it was not a graded part
of the comprehensive exam,
but it was an amusing question.
I won't answer it here because
we're on tape,
[LAUGHTER] but think about it.
I may not be obvious.
Several of them are rich.
It's just the question of who
is the most rich.
Anyway, before they were rich
they came up with this
algorithm.
They've come up with many
algorithms since,
even after getting rich,
believe it or not.
What we want is a good pivot,
guaranteed good pivot.
Random pivot is going to be
really good.
And so the simplest algorithm
is just pick a random pivot.
It's going to be good with high
probability.
We want to force a good pivot
deterministically.
And the new idea here is we're
going to generate it
recursively.
What else could we do but
recurse?
Well, you should know from your
recurrences that if we did two
recursive calls on problems of
half the size and we have a
linear extra work that's the
mergesort recurrence,
T(n)=2[T(n/2)+Theta(n)].
You should recite in your
sleep.
That's n lg n.
So we cannot recurse on two
problems of half the size.
We've got to do better.
Somehow these recursions have
to add up to strictly less than
n.
That's the magic of this
algorithm.
So this will just be called
select instead of rand-select.
And it really depends on an
array, but I will focus on the
i-th element that we want to
select and the size of the array
that we want to select in.
And I am going to write this
algorithm slightly less formally
than randomize-select because
it's a bit higher level of an
algorithm.
And let me draw over here the
picture of the algorithm.
The first step is sort of the
weirdest and it's one of the key
ideas.
You take your elements,
and they are in no particular
order, so instead of drawing
them on a line,
I am going to draw them in a 5
by n over 5 grid.
Why not?
This, unfortunately,
take a little while to draw,
but it will take you equally
long so I will take my time.
It doesn't really matter what
the width is,
but it should be width n over 5
so make sure you draw your
figure accordingly.
Width n over 5,
but the height should be
exactly 5.
I think I got it right.
I can count that high.
Here is 5.
And this should be,
well, you know,
our number may not be divisible
by 5, so maybe it ends off in
sort of an odd way.
But what I would like is that
these chunks should be floor of
n over 5.
And then we will have,
at most, four elements left
over.
So I am going to ignore those.
They don't really matter.
It's just an additive constant.
Here is my array.
I just happened to write it in
this funny way.
And I will call these vertical
things groups.
I would circle them,
and I did that in my notes,
but things get really messy if
you start circling.
This diagram is going to get
really full, just to warn you.
By the end it will be almost
unintelligible,
but there it is.
If you are really feeling
bored, you can draw this a few
times.
And you should draw how it
grows.
So there are the groups,
vertical groups of five.
Next step.
The second step is to recurse.
This is where things are a bit
unusual, well,
even more unusual.
Oops, sorry.
I really should have had a line
between one and two so I am
going to have to move this down
and insert it here.
I also, in step one,
want to find the median of each
group.
What I would like to do is just
imagine this figure,
each of the five elements in
each group gets reorganized so
that the middle one is the
median.
So I am going to call these the
medians of each group.
I have five elements so the
median is right in the middle.
There are two elements less
than the median,
two elements greater than the
median.
Again, we're assuming all
elements are distinct.
So there they are.
I compute them.
How long does that take me?
N over five groups,
each with five elements,
compute the median of each one?
Sorry?
Yeah, 2 times n over 5.
It's theta n,
that's all I need to know.
I mean, you're counting
comparisons, which is good.
It's definitely Theta(n).
The point is within each group,
I only have to do a constant
number of comparisons because
it's a constant number of
elements.
It doesn't matter.
You could use randomize select
for all I care.
No matter what you do,
it can only take a constant
number of comparisons.
As long as you don't make a
comparison more than once.
So this is easy.
You could sort the five numbers
and then look at the third one,
it doesn't matter because there
are only five of them.
That's one nifty idea.
Already we have some elements
that are sort of vaguely in the
middle but just of the group.
And we've only done linear
work.
So doing well so far.
Now we get to the second step,
which I started to write
before, where we recurse.
So the next idea is,
well, we have these floor over
n over 5 medians.
I am going to compute the
median of those medians.
I am imagining that I
rearranged these.
And, unfortunately,
it's an even number,
there are six of them,
but I will rearrange so that
this guy, I have drawn in a
second box, is the median of
these elements so that these two
elements are strictly less than
this guy, these three elements
are strictly greater than this
guy.
Now, that doesn't directly tell
me anything, it would seem,
about any of the elements out
here.
We will come back to that.
In fact, it does tell us about
some of the elements.
But right now this element is
just the median of these guys.
Each of these guys is a median
of five elements.
That's all we know.
If we do that recursively,
this is going to take T of n
over 5 time.
So far so good.
We can afford a recursion on a
problem of size n over 5 and
linear work.
We know that works out to
linear time.
But there is more.
We're obviously not done yet.
The next step is x is our
partition element.
We partition there.
The rest of the algorithm is
just like randomized partition,
so we're going to define k to
be the rank of x.
And this can be done,
I mean it's n minus r plus 1 or
whatever, but I'm not going to
write out how to do that because
we're at a higher level here.
But it can be done.
And then we have the three-way
branching.
So if i happens to equal k
we're happy.
The pivot element is the
element we're looking for,
but more likely i is either
less than k or it is bigger than
k.
And then we make the
appropriate recursive call,
so here we recursively select
the i-th smallest element --
-- in the lower part of the
array.
Left of the partition element.
Otherwise, we recursively
select the i minus k-th smallest
element in the upper part of the
array.
I am writing this at a high
level because we've already seen
it.
All of this is the same as the
last couple steps of randomized
select.
That is the algorithm.
The real question is why does
it work?
Why is this linear time?
The first question is what's
the recurrence?
We cannot quite write it down
yet because we don't know how
big these recursive subproblems
could be.
We're going to either recurse
in the lower part or the upper
part, that's just like before.
If we're unlucky and we have a
split of like zero to n minus
one, this is going to be a
quadratic time algorithm.
The claim is that this
partition element is guaranteed
to be pretty good and good
enough.
The running time of this thing
will be T of something times n,
and we don't know what the
something is yet.
How big could it be?
Well, I could ask you.
But we're sort of indirect here
so I will tell you.
We have already a recursive
call of T of n over 5.
It better be that whatever
constant, so it's going to be
something times n,
it better be that that constant
is strictly less than 4/5.
If it's equal to 4/5 then
you're not splitting up the
problem enough to get an n lg n
running time.
If it's strictly less than 4/5
then you're reducing the problem
by at least a constant factor.
In the sense if you add up all
the recursive subproblems,
n over 5 and something times n,
you get something that is a
constant strictly less than one
times n.
That forces the work to be
geometric.
If it's geometric you're going
to get linear time.
So this is intuition but it's
the right intuition.
Whenever you're aiming for
linear time keep that in mind.
If you're doing a
divide-and-conquer,
you've got to get the total
subproblem size to be some
constant less than one times n.
That will work.
OK, so we've got to work out
this constant here.
And we're going to use this
figure, which so far looks
surprisingly uncluttered.
Now we will make it cluttered.
What I would like to do is draw
an arrow between two vertices,
two points, elements,
whatever you want to call them.
Let's call them a and b.
And I want to orient the arrow
so it points to a larger value,
so this means that a is less
than b.
This is notation just for the
diagram.
And so this element,
I am going to write down what I
know.
This element is the median of
these five elements.
I will suppose that it is drawn
so that these elements are
larger than the median,
these elements are smaller than
the median.
Therefore, I have arrows like
this.
Here is where I wish I had some
colored chalk.
This is just stating this guy
is in the middle of those five
elements.
I know that in every single
column.
Here is where the diagram
starts to get messy.
I am not done yet.
Now, we also know that this
element is the median of the
medians.
Of all the squared elements,
this guy is the middle.
And I will draw it so that
these are the ones smaller than
the median, these are the ones
larger than the median.
I mean the algorithm cannot do
this.
It doesn't necessarily know how
all this works.
I guess it could,
but this is just for analysis
purposes.
We know this guy is bigger than
that one and bigger than that
one.
We don't directly know about
the other elements.
We just know that that one is
bigger than both of those and
this guy is smaller than these.
Now, that is as messy as the
figure will get.
Now, the nice thing about less
than is that it's a transitive
relation.
If I have a directed path in
this graph, I know that this
element is strictly less than
that element because this is
less than that one and this is
less than that one.
Even though directly I only
know within a column and within
this middle row,
I actually know that this
element --
This is x, by the way.
This element is larger than all
of these elements because it's
larger than this one and this
one and each of these is larger
than all of those by these
arrows.
I also know that all of these
elements in this rectangle here,
and you don't have to do this
but I will make the background
even more cluttered.
All of these elements in this
rectangle are greater than or
equal to this one and all of the
elements in this rectangle are
less than or equal to x.
Now, how many are there?
Well, this is roughly halfway
along the set of groups and this
is 3/5 of these columns.
So what we get is that there
are at least --
We have n over 5 groups and we
have half of the groups that
we're looking at here roughly,
so let's call that floor of n
over 2, and then within each
group we have three elements.
So we have at least 3 times
floor of floor of n over 5 over
2 n floor elements that are less
than or equal to x.
And we have the same that are
greater than or equal to x.
Let me simplify this a little
bit more.
I can also give you some more
justification,
and we drew the picture,
but just for why this is true.
We have at least n over 5 over
2 group medians that are less
than or equal to x.
This is the argument we use.
We have half of the group
medians are less than or equal
to x because x is the median of
the group median,
so that is no big surprise.
This is almost an equality but
we're making floors so it's
greater than or equal to.
And then, for each group
median, we know that there are
three elements there that are
less than or equal to that group
median.
So, by transitivity,
they're also less than or equal
to x.
We get this number times three.
This is actually just floor of
n over 10.
I was being unnecessarily
complicated there,
but that is where it came from.
What we know is that this thing
is now at least 3 times n over
10, which is roughly 3/10 of
elements are in one side.
In fact, at least 3/10 of the
elements are in each side.
Therefore, each side has at
most 7/10 elements roughly.
So the number here will be
7/10.
And, if I'm lucky,
7/10 plus 1/5 is strictly less
than one.
I believe it is,
but I have trouble working with
tenths.
I can only handle powers of
two.
What we're going to use is a
minor simplification,
which just barely still works,
is a little bit easier to think
about.
It's mainly to get rid of this
floor because the floor is
annoying.
And we don't really have a
sloppiness lemma that applies
here.
It turns out if n is
sufficiently large,
3 times floor of n over 10 is
greater than or equal to 1/4.
Quarters I can handle.
The claim is that each group
has size at least 1/4,
therefore each group has size
at most 3/4 because there's a
quarter on the side.
This will be 3/4.
And I can definitely tell that
1/5 is less than 1/4.
This is going to add up to
something strictly less than one
and then it will work.
How is my time?
Good.
At this point,
the rest of the analysis is
easy.
How the heck you would come up
with this algorithm,
you realize that this is
clearly a really good choice for
finding a partition element,
just barely good enough that
both recursions add up to linear
time.
Well, that's why it took so
many famous people.
Especially in quizzes,
but I think in general this
class, you won't have to come up
with an algorithm this clever
because you can just use this
algorithm to find the median.
And the median is a really good
partition element.
Now that you know this
algorithm, now that we're beyond
1973, you don't need to know how
to do this.
I mean you should know how this
algorithm works,
but you don't need to do this
in another algorithm because you
can just say run this algorithm,
you will get the median in
linear time, and then you can
partition to the left and the
right.
And then the left and the right
will have exactly equal size.
Great.
This is a really powerful
subroutine.
You could use this all over the
place, and you will on Friday.
Have I analyzed the running
time pretty much?
The first step is linear.
The second step is T of n over
01:04:18,806 --> 00:00:05,000
The third step,
I didn't write it,
is linear.
And then the last step is just
a recursive call.
And now we know that this is
3/4.
I get this recurrence.
T of n is, I'll say at most,
T of n over 5 plus T of 3/4n.
You could have also used 7/10.
It would give the same answer,
but you would also need a floor
so we won't do that.
I claim that this is linear.
How should I prove it?
Substitution.
Claim that T of n is at most
again c times n,
that will be enough.
Proof is by substitution.
Again, we assume this is true
for smaller n.
And want to prove it for n.
We have T of n is at most this
thing.
T of n over 5.
And by induction,
because n of 5 is smaller than
n, we know that this is at most
c.
Let me write it as c over 5
times n.
Sure, why not.
Then we have here 3/4cn.
And then we have a linear term.
Now, unfortunately,
I have to deal with things that
are not powers of two.
I will cheat and look at my
notes.
This is also known as 19/20
times c times n plus theta n.
And the point is just that this
is strictly less than one.
Because it's strictly less than
one, I can write this as one
times c of n minus some
constant, here it happens to be
1/20, as long as I have
something left over here,
1/20 times c times n.
Then I have this annoying theta
n term which I want to get rid
of because I want this to be
nonnegative.
But it is nonnegative,
as long as I set c to be
really, really large,
at least 20 times whatever
constant is here.
So this is at most c times n
for c sufficiently large.
And, oh, by the way,
if n is less than or equal to
50, which we used up here,
then T of n is a constant,
it doesn't really matter what
you do, and T of n is at most c
times n for c sufficiently
large.
That proves this claim.
Of course, the constant here is
pretty damn big.
It depends exactly what the
constants and the running times
are, which depends on your
machine, but practically this
algorithm is not so hot because
the constants are pretty big.
Even though this element is
guaranteed to be somewhere
vaguely in the middle,
and even though these
recursions add up to strictly
less than n and it's geometric,
it's geometric because the
problem is reducing by at least
a factor of 19/20 each time.
So it actually takes a while
for the problem to get really
small.
Practically you probably don't
want to use this algorithm
unless you cannot somehow flip
coins.
The randomized algorithm works
really, really fast.
Theoretically this is your
dream, the best you could hope
for because it's linear time and
you need linear time as
guaranteed linear time.
I will mention,
before we end,
an exercise.
Why did we use groups of five?
Why not groups of three?
As you might guess,
the answer is because it
doesn't work with groups of
three.
But it's quite constructive to
find out why.
If you work through this math
with groups of three instead of
groups of five,
you will find that you don't
quite get the problem reduction
that you need.
Five is the smallest number for
which this works.
It would work with seven,
but theoretically not any
better than a constant factor.
Any questions?
All right.
Then recitation Friday.
Homework lab Sunday.
Problem set due Monday.
Quiz one in two weeks.